[Music]  i bet you have a a new home this is  quite a spacious home how many bathrooms  you have in this home well i don't know  i think you do know how many bathrooms  do you have i don't know i don't go  around count my bathroom well i did  was that you yes that was me i saw this  creepy guy counting bathrooms at the  house creepy guy well who would count  bathrooms how do you know how many  bathrooms i have in the house i i how  many do i have 17  well you have 17 bathrooms sir you need  that at my age my dad told me a long  time ago  you need a lot of bathrooms always  within 15 minutes  my dad told me right before he passed  away he said you're going to hit sixty  one of these i'm gonna give you two  rules number one  never pass up a bathroom  number two use every erection to its  full potential oh my god  that's what he said to its full  potential yes so if your wife's not  around you like hammer nails with it or  something  well i want to know  i want to know